[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la papouasie
occidentale ce territoire qui fait
partie de l'indonésie cherche depuis
plus de 50 ans obtenir son indépendance
le conflit entre le gouvernement et les
forces indépendantistes s'enflamme avec
une nouvelle vigueur et risque d'avoir
des répercussions sur toute la région
quel est donc l'ampleur actuelle de
cette confrontation qui se joue en
papouasie occidentale début mais
l'indonésie déploie un contingent
supplémentaire dans la partie ouest de
l'île de nouvelle guinée un acte qui
fait suite au meurtre du chef de l'
agence de renseignement de papouasie
organisé par la force de guérilla locale
résultat des milliers de personnes sont
fille dans la jungle par crainte de la
répression en même temps une fissure
apparaît entre les deux plus grands
mouvements indépendantistes du pays le
mouvement uni pour la libération de la
papouasie occidentale et l'organisation
pour une papouasie libre
la pomme de discorde est temps la façon
de mener la lutte pour l'indépendance à
l'international ce sont principalement
les états de la mélanésie tels que le
vanuatu et les îles salomon qui
expriment leur solidarité avec les
indépendantistes de son côté dans sa
lutte contre eux jakarta bénéficie du
soutien de l'australie qui entraîne ses
forces de l'ordre
la papouasie nouvelle guinée quand elle
reste plutôt neutre
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette région rebelle
indonésienne c'est le blitz le conflit
touche en effet deux provinces
administratives de l'indonésie la
papouasie est la papouasie occidentale
elle occupe la partie ouest de l'île de
nouvelle guinée sont parfois confondu à
tort avec la papouasie nouvelle guinée
un état indépendant qui se trouve à
l'est de l'île afin d'éviter la
confusion le terme géographique de
papouasie occidentale est souvent
préféré aux notions administrative
désignant les deux provinces rebelles
les racines du conflit trouvent leur
source dans l'époque de la
décolonisation les pays-bas
reconnaissent l'indépendance de
l'indonésie en 1949 mais maintiennent le
contrôle sur la papouasie occidentale
dans les années 60
cette partie de l'île de nouvelle guinée
est transféré à l'indonésie aujourd'hui
les deux provinces disposent d'une
autonomie considérable en vertu d'une
loi sur le statut spécial de 2001
pourtant un certain nombre de groupes
souhaitent une indépendance totale et
évoque l'idée d'un référendum mais
jakarta refusant à l'est de l'archipel
indonésien la papouasie occidentale est
le théâtre d'une rébellion qui ne fait
pas souvent la une des journaux
elle dure depuis plus de 50 ans et
opposent des groupes rebelles aux forces
indonésienne jakarta renforce sa
présence dans la zone du conflit et
mènent des opérations contre les
insurgés
le nude pointe du doigt le gouvernement
indonésien et l'accuse d'un recours à la
force excessive les états mélanésiens
expriment leur solidarité avec les
indépendantistes et accuse jakarta de
violations des droits de l'homme la
papouasie nouvelle guinée quant à elle
élit de prendre parti craignant la
résurgence du séparatisme dans son pays
l'australie se range du côté de
l'indonésie en plus du soutien
diplomatique
canberra entraîne les forces de l'ordre
indonésienne qui participent aux
opérations spéciales en papouasie
occidentale
alors comment ce conflit peut-il
influencer l'échiquier régional comment
les rebelles locaux essaient de saper
l'autorité de jakarta sur la papouasie
occidentale enfin quelles perspectives
se dessinent pour le futur de cette
partie 2
il répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons frédéric angle vielle
professeur des universités à
l'université de la nouvelle calédonie
monsieur angle viel bonjour bonjour
pensez vous que cette fois ci les
indépendantistes réussiront à progresser
un peu dans leur cause ou une fois de
plus la situation on n'aboutira à rien
lorsqu'on se pose la question si les
indépendantistes papou obtiendront plus
de résultats aujourd'hui qu'hier
bon il faut évidemment replacer sa au
point de vue historique puisque il
s'était battu mais de façon très
épisodique contre la puissance coloniale
donc hollandaise puis la hollande donc
en 1963 a cédé la papouasie occidentale
à l'indonésie qui devait organiser un
référendum
il ya eu donc eu un référendum en 1969
mais il ne concernait que 1026 pas
pousse sur à peu près 800 mille
habitants qui à l'unanimité en voté à
l'époque pour entrer dans l'anneau daisy
donc c'est à ce moment là que réellement
s'est mis en place petit à petit à
mouvements autonomistes indépendantistes
qui a progressé au fil des années donc
on peut dire aujourd'hui que ce
mouvement continue à progresser mais il
est confronté à plusieurs choses d'abord
effectivement la transmigration actes
ont mis en place des indonésiens qui
fait que la population non pas pour
maintenant et à peu près équilibrés avec
la population papous dans ces deux
provinces
d'autre part le fait que par rapport à
l'ensemble de la population donc
indonésienne ils représentent que la
plaie de province 2 % et la population a
pu 1% uniquement ici de cette population
indonésienne et le régime indonésien a
toujours je dirais essayer de contrôler
et de réprimer ces mouvements
indépendantistes et à certains moments
en partie en 2019 2020 de façon à
séduire
donc il y à une progression mais une
progression qui et je dirai temporisé au
relativisé par la différence de taille
qu'il peut y avoir
puisque nous avons d'un côté 10 millions
d'habitants et de l'autre côté à peu
près
donc deux millions cinq cent mille pas
pourquoi y at il tant de friction dans
l'opposition papou parce que on sait
qu'il ya plusieurs courants il ya une
espèce de lutte pour le pouvoir qui s'y
installent alors on se pose toujours la
question pourquoi est ce qu'il y a des
centres de concurrence de friction parmi
les différents mouvements de libération
papous on peut y voir de raison une
résidence traditionnelle une raison
moderne la région traditionnelle c'est
que dans la culture traditionnelle
mélanésienne papous on a ce qu'on
appelle des big man c'est à dire des
personnes qui monte petit à petit dans
la société par elle même en particulier
en faisant des des grands en festin où
les cochons sont tués en grand nombre et
ce n'est pas héréditaire ça veut dire
que chaque comme pour devenir à big man
doit petit à petit grimper dans la
hiérarchie sociale et en particulier par
des rites initiatiques donc qu'il y à un
système où à chaque génération
ce sont deux nouveaux hommes qui
apparaissent on a parlé d'anarchie
paternelle pour l'apa poids la
population pas cool ça c'est l'aspect
traditionnel donc une société qui n'est
pas organisé pour répondre aux demandes
politiques modernes
l'autre aspect c'est que les papous sont
avant tout des agriculteurs des
campagnards qui vivent de cultures
traditionnelles et face à eux il y à la
modernité le monde urbain le monde des
communications
donc il ya le fait qu' il y a
différenciation importantes entre les
populations papou traditionnels et les
populations indonésienne qui se sont
installés dans les deux provinces
merci beaucoup monsieur angle viennent
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous retrouvons
à la fin de cette émission pour plus de
détails sur ce thème
merci encore les violences continuent à
secouer la papouasie occidentale fin
juin 2021 la police indonésienne pointe
du doigt les rebelles le pot les accusés
du meurtre de quatre ouvriers les
rebelles eux mènent une campagne assez
intense contre la présence de l'état
dans la région à leur tour plusieurs ong
accusent les forces de l'ordre de faire
usage de la force excessive le 7 juin
trois civils sont tués lors d'une
opération contre les rebelles
trois autres sont blessées une vague de
violence ou coup la papouasie
occidentale depuis septembre dernier
lorsque des centaines d'étudiants
descendent dans la rue pour protester
contre une possible prolongation de la
loi sur l'autonomie spécial ce statut
d'autonomie instauré il ya 20 ans ne les
arrange pas ils réclament la mise en
place d'un référendum sur l'indépendance
totale de cette région de l'indonésie
les forces de l'ordre indonésienne tente
de disperser la foule
bilan plusieurs morts des blessés et des
dizaines d'arrestations
la communauté internationale s'alarme
nous sommes préoccupés par l'escaladé de
la violence au cours des dernières
semaines et des derniers mois dans les
province indonésienne de papouasie et de
papouasie occidentale et par le risque
accru de regain de tension et de
violence au moins 1,8 million de
personnes sur cinq et demi au total
vivent dans la région soutiennent
l'initiative d'un référendum
et cela pour plusieurs raisons il ya
d'abord le facteur historique car la
papouasie occidentale ne faisait pas
initialement partie de l'état indonésien
les pays-bas anciennes métropoles las
aide à l'indonésie en 1963 la population
de la papouasie occidentale diffère en
outre de celle du reste de l'indonésie
en termes de racines de culture et de
religion
et puis il ya aussi les inégalités
socio-économiques l'une des régions les
plus riches du pays en ressources
naturelles la papouasie occidentale
reste paradoxalement l'une des plus
pauvres
avec plus de 20% de la population vivant
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
pourtant le gouvernement refuse de
parler d'un référendum sur
l'indépendance selon jakarta les papous
ont déjà eu la chance de vivre
séparément mais on préférait rester avec
l'indonésie
le référendum a eu lieu en novembre 1969
il a été ratifiée par l'assemblée
générale des nations unies et stipule
que la papouasie est une partie légitime
de l'indonésie par conséquent il n'y en
aura plus il est impossible pour l'onu
de prendre une décision deux fois sur la
même question entre le gouvernement et
les partisans de l'indépendance la
tension monte fin avril lorsque le chef
de l' agence de renseignement de
papouasie et tuée par les rebelles en
représailles le gouvernement aux coupes
internet dans cette partie du pays et
déploie une brigade spéciale de 400
soldats connu en indonésie sous le nom
de force du diable des milliers de
personnes fuient leurs villages et
partant la jungle par crainte de la
répression
les militaires établi sans contrôle sur
les écoles et les hôpitaux de la
papouasie occidentale dans cette récente
escalade l'un des rôles les plus actifs
et joué par le mouvement uni pour la
libération de la papouasie occidentale
son chef benny wenda qui vit en exil au
royaume-uni annonce en décembre dernier
la formation d'un gouvernement
intérimaire indépendant de jakarta début
mai le cabinet autoproclamé est formé
composé de 12 ministères il
travaillerait clandestinement sur le
territoire de la papouasie occidentale
et aurez comme principales missions de
saper le pouvoir indonésien sur la
région de papouasie formation de cette
force secrète et pourtant accueillie
froidement par d'autres groupes
indépendantistes actif aussi dans la
région par exemple l'autre au
gouvernement auto-proclamé présidée par
l'activiste politique
yab s'y atteler n'ayant aucun pouvoir
réel cet organe se considère néanmoins
comme le seul représentant de la
population de la papouasie occidentale
l'autre au mouvement séparatiste rival
et l'organisation pour une papouasie
libre sont l armée ne reconnaît pas la
légitimité du gouvernement de luanda et
lui reprochent surtout de mener la lutte
depuis l'étranger
le tpn pb au pm remet également en
question les motivations des dirigeants
de l'ue elle mwp qui n'ont jamais fait
partie de la lutte de libération à
l'intérieur de la papouasie occidentale
et vivent dans la sécurité privilégié
d'oxford au royaume-uni pour le
gouvernement indonésien c'est l'activité
de cette organisation pour une papouasie
libre qui représente une réelle menace
pour la région
fin avril 2021 jakarta désigne l armée
de l'organisation pour une papouasie
libre comme terrorisme un accent c'est
étendre les pouvoirs de la police qui
pourra désormais détenir des personnes
sans inculpation jusqu'à 21 jours et
intercepter les communications
téléphoniques des personnes soupçonnées
de terrorisme
alors où les forces indépendantistes
cherche-t-elle un soutien diplomatique
qui est leur tend la main et qui au
contraire tente de les étouffer
enfin comment cette partie de l'île at
elle été rattachée à l'indonésie
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
en papouasie occidentale attention
continue de grimper et l'armée
indonésienne met une pression maximale
sur les mouvements indépendantistes qui
continuent leur lutte armée depuis des
dizaines d'années ancienne colonie
néerlandaise l'indonésie proclame son
indépendance en 1945
c'est le début d'un conflit armé avec la
métropole qui dure quatre ans et je
finis par la reconnaissance de
l'indonésie par les pays-bas le seul
bout de l'ancienne colonie qu'amsterdam
réussi à conserver malgré les
revendications indonésienne et la partie
ouest de l'île de nouvelle guinée
pourtant sous la pression internationale
les pays-bas transfert en 1963 le
territoire à l'indonésie un référendum
sur le maintien de la région au sein du
pays où son indépendance doit être
organisé au plus tard en 1969
cependant lors du vote seuls un millier
de représentants sont choisis par
l'administration indonésiennes pour y
participer
sans surprise le vote et à l'unanimité
en faveur d'une intégration à
l'indonésie et le résultat est un
terrines et par l'onu à la suite du
rattachement à l'indonésie un mouvement
indépendantiste se créer l'organisation
pour une papouasie libre ses membres
commencent peu à peu à organiser des
actions de guérilla contre l'armée
indonésienne ou contre des sites
d'exploitation de ressources minières
ces actes déclenché une vague de
répression du côté du gouvernement un
rapport de la commission asiatique des
droits de l'homme montré qu'en 1977 1978
l'armée indonésienne est allé jusqu'à
utiliser du napalm pour bombarder des
villages dans la région de baliem
faisant au total plusieurs milliers de
victimes
la tensions s'apaisent à la fin des
années 90 après le départ du président
indonésien suharto qui dirige l
indonésie d'une main de fer depuis plus
de 30 ans de fait en 2000 ans un statut
d'autonomie spéciale est accordée à la
partie ouest de l'île de nouvelle guinée
pour une période de 20 ans prévoyant
entre autres l'allocation de fonds
supplémentaires à cette région et la
création d'une assemblée locale mme
néanmoins les réformes attendues peine à
se concrétiser et les fonds
supplémentaires sont largement détournés
sans profiter à la population
l'intensification de l'exploitation des
ressources notamment forestière de l'île
entraîne toujours plus de mécontentement
de la population qui voit son habitat
naturel saccagé sans en retirer de
compensation en 2014
l'arrivée au pouvoir du président joe
cole we do do entraîne de nouveaux
espoirs
fraîchement élu widodo décidé de la mise
en oeuvre de projets d'infrastructures
afin de favoriser le développement
économique de la région qui est toujours
l'une des plus pauvres de l'indonésie
cependant les aspirations à
l'indépendance ne faiblissent pas trois
mouvements politiques indépendantistes
s'unissent en un mouvement uni pour la
libération de la papouasie occidentale
ce groupe devient de plus en plus
visible au niveau international il est
notamment admis en 2015 comme
observateur par le groupe fer de lance
mélanésiens une alliance de plusieurs
pays de la région
ces mêmes pays qui aborde à plusieurs
reprises la question pape ou à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu
de plus en plus aiguës la crise dans la
papouasie occidentale passe largement en
dessous des radars de la communauté
internationale et les militants locaux
tentent tant bien que mal d'attirer
l'attention du monde
ainsi en ce moment d'autres tensions
benny wenda interpelle la chine
mon peuple n'est pas en sécurité sous la
direction de l'indonésie presque cinq
cent mille hommes femmes et enfants ont
été tués depuis 1960
si la chine souhaite nous soutenir nous
les accueillerons bras ouverts la chine
de son côté reste plutôt silencieuse sur
le sujet en effet elle a beaucoup à
perdre car l'indonésie est un maillon
clé de l'initiative chinoise des
nouvelles routes de la soie réseau
mondial d'infrastructures promu par
pékin pour accroître son influence
économique et politique
plusieurs projets chinois sont déjà en
cours de construction c'est pourquoi la
chine ne peut pas se permettre de se
fâcher avec l'indonésie en soutenant sa
province rebelle
néanmoins la presse locale ne cesse
d'évoquer le soutien discret de pékin à
la papouasie occidentale selon
journal of political risque la chine
serait en discussion avec les militants
pour leur offrir de l'aide financière
la raison d'après le même journal en est
sa relation de plus en plus tendue avec
l'indonésie sujet d'irritation
le contentieux territorial en mer de
chine méridionale ont encore le problème
des ouïghours
or cet appui chinois aux rebelles papou
reste pour l'instant hypothétique
d'ailleurs le gouvernement provisoire de
la papouasie occidentale ne compte pas
seulement sur l'appui chinois
il s'adresse plutôt à toute la
communauté internationale
nous cherchons une assistance
internationale politique et humanitaire
via des efforts diplomatiques et la
communication ouverte avec tous les pays
membres de l'onu
pourtant qui sur la scène internationale
soutient vraiment les indépendantistes
pas pour l'instant ce sont surtout les
pays de la mélanésie tels que le vanuatu
et les îles salomon solidaire de la
petite région qui s'identifient comme
mais l'alésienne ils vont jusqu'à le nul
pour attirer l'attention mondiale depuis
un demi siècle déjà la communauté
internationale assiste à la panoplie de
tortures meurtres exploitation violences
sexuelles et détention arbitraire
exercée par l'indonésie contre les
habitants de la papouasie occidentale
nous appelons le conseil des droits
humains a enquêté sur ces cas nous
appelons aussi nos homologues à travers
le monde à soutenir le droit légal de la
papouasie occidentale à
l'autodétermination lancé à titre
individuel en 2017 cet appel ne cesse
d'être amplifié par les pays mélanésiens
et du pacifique en août 2019
dix-huit membres du forum du pacifique
exige de l'indonésie et autorise une
visite du haut commissaire de l'onu aux
droits de l'homme en papouasie
occidentale
six mois plus tard 79 pays de
l'organisation des pays d'afrique des
caraïbes et du pacifique euros joignent
cet appel en dehors de la région il a
reçu l'appui du royaume uni et des pays
bas
tout cela sans résultat l'indonésie n'a
toujours pas admis la visite du haut
commissaire onusien dans la région
rebelle
le nu
de son côté refuse de s'immiscer dans la
situation face à la violence actuelle
l'action onusienne se limite à des
déclarations
nous appelons le gouvernement indonésien
respecter le droit à la liberté
d'expression au rassemblement pacifique
et à la réunion conformément à ses
obligations internationales
il y a un besoin pressant d'une plate
forme de dialogue constructif et
inclusif avec la papouasie et la
papouasie occidentale en 2010 est déjà à
l'onu rejette la pétition des papous
occidentaux appelant à respecter leur
droit à l'autodétermination
la raison en est technique la région ne
fait pas partie de la liste onusienne
des territoires non autonomes régions
non des colonisés qui n'ont pas encore
exercé leur droit de disposer
d'elle-même et ce n'est pas la seule
porte qui se ferme devant la papouasie
occidentale
sa voisine la papouasie nouvelle guinée
refuse aussi de se mêler du sujet ce
pays partagent l'identité culturelle et
nationale de la papouasie occidentale
est nombre de ses habitants soutiennent
les séparatistes ainsi en septembre 2019
des milliers de pas pointer aux guinéens
se rassemblent en solidarité avec la
région indonésienne et exiger un
référendum sur son indépendance
pourtant la papouasie nouvelle guinée
fait aussi face à un mouvement
séparatiste au sein du pays à
bougainville
du coup le gouvernement reste prudent
sur le sujet de la région voisine la
papouasie occidentale est un problème
intérieur de l'indonésie
ce que chacun de nous ressent à ce sujet
n'est pas vraiment important tant que
cela se passe de l'autre côté de la
frontière
quant aux acteurs plus important au
niveau mondial comme par exemple les
états unis préfèrent aussi gardé le
silence de fête au sujet de la papouasie
occidentale l'indonésie ne peut compter
que sur l'appui de l'australie les deux
pays coopèrent étroitement dans le
domaine du commerce et de la sécurité ce
dernier volet se base sur le traité de
lombok signé en 2006 il proscrit tout
soutien éventuel de l'australie au
groupe séparatiste indonésien en outre
canberra sur l'entraînement des forces
de l'ordre indonésienne et compris des
détachements anti terroristes impliqués
dans les opérations
papouasie occidentale peut discuter au
niveau international la crise en
papouasie occidentale ne cesse de
s'intensifier
la résolution via un dialogue national
est elle possible
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons
de nouveau fredrik angle vielle
professeur des universités à
l'université de la nouvelle calédonie
monsieur angliviel pourquoi selon vous
les pays mélanésiens soutient-il la
cause pape ou alors les pays mélanésiens
soutiennent la poste n'impose pas pou il
faut savoir que les autres pays
mélanésiens sont donc l'autre partie de
la papouasie la papouasie nouvelle
guinée les îles salomon le vanuatu la
nouvelle calédonie et fidji qui est
moitié mélanésienne et moitié
polynésienne ils ont du reste créer un
groupe qu'on appelle le fer de lance
mélanésiens alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'à la fois ils soutiennent les
mouvements indépendantistes mais
j'allais dire légèrement sens sans force
puisque autant il avait soutenu les
mouvements indépendantistes en nouvelle
calédonie de façon forte dans les années
1980-1990 autant là leurs propos sont
généralement assez lénifiant et il est à
remarquer qu'ils ont acceptée en 2007
que l'indonésie soit un membre associé
du fer de lance mélanésiens alors que
pour le principal mouvement
indépendantiste d2 on province papoue de
l'indonésie ils ne les ont pris que
comme observateurs ce qui montre bien
que le fer de lance mais annaysiens
restent circonspects par rapport à la
question indonésienne pa pou pa pou
indonésienne peut-on dire que le manque
de réaction de la part du reste de la
communauté internationale signifie que
le stade sukru finalement satisfait tout
le monde
alors est-ce que le statu quo au
satisfait tout le monde au point de vue
international
on peut donner plusieurs types de
réponses d'abord les états unis en sur
le plan économique sur le plan financier
des intérêts dans ces deux provinces
pape ou de l'indonésie en particulier
pour une mine d'or des mines de cuivre
voir des mines d'argent ou de nickel
d'autre part si on prend l'eau
rallye l'australie souhaite l'alliance
avec l'indonésie qui est quand même le
plus grand pays musulman de la région
il se rappelle de l'attentât islamiste
qui avait eu lieu à ben ali contre donc
des citoyens australiens dans ce qu'ils
veulent c'est surtout une entente avec
l'état indonésien
la france par exemple et qui est à la
fois très loin mais très proche avec la
nouvelle calédonie préfère gérer le
problème interne à la nouvelle calédonie
et ne pas s'ingérer dans les problèmes
des autres pays de la zone
le seul pays qui pourrait à terme je
dirais poser un certain nombre de
questions par rapport à la situation en
indonésie c'est finalement la chine
ce grand voisin de l'indonésie qui
partout actuellement dans le pacifique
mais à des pions c'est que ils ont
financé par exemple au vanuatu
justement le bâtiment du fer de lance
mais alésien on sait que il s'installe
un peu partout dans la région pacifique
dans l'océanie et donc la chine demain
pourrait se poser un ensemble de
questions par rapport à ces tentatives
d'autonomie ou d'indépendance
comment voyez-vous la résolution de ce
conflit un dialogue national
ou plutôt international avec la
participation des pays comme la chine ou
l'australie
alors lorsqu'on se pose la question de
la solution de ce conflit
on aimerait que par l'onu par des
organisations régionales il puisse y
avoir des solutions trouvées mais
prenons l'exemple du forum du pacifique
qui a été créé dès 1971 et qui comprend
normand tous les pays indépendants de la
robe la région océanie on s'aperçoit que
il n'y a pas du tout les mouvements
indépendantistes pape ou de l'indonésie
par contre l'indonésie est quand même
présent totti du forum du pacifique au
titre des réunions pas ce forum
donc on voit que le la parole des
indépendantistes papous et peu reprise
dans la région
la deuxième aspect c'est la
disproportion entre les deux points de
vue on a
une indonésie qui représentent quasiment
deux millions de kilomètres carrés les
deux provinces dont pape ou de
l'indonésie font 400 mille kilomètres
carrés
c'est à dire que la partie pape ou de
l'indonésie représente 20% de la
superficie de l'indonésie donc on voit
mal déjà l'indonésie se séparer de 20 %
de sa superficie
sachant que l'indonésie représente 270
millions d'habitants qu'elle est très
peuplée et que la région justement pas
pour les deux province papoue ce sens
les régions sous peuplés entre
guillemets de la papouasie puisque dans
cette région pour simplifier nous avons
5 millions d'habitants moitié pas pour
moitié un migrant plus ou moins récents
mal et indonésiens donc on a dans les
deux provinces de papous de noël de
l'indonésie on a deux pour cent de la
population a des dizaines par rapport à
20% de la superficie de l'indonésie dont
on voit mal comment il pourrait avoir
une solution pacifique demain s'il n'y a
pas un accord interne c'est à dire que
cette loi d'autonomie spéciale donne
suffisamment de liberté et de je dirais
de respect aux populations papou pour
peu une entente sur place
merci beaucoup fredrik angle vielle je
rappelle vous êtes professeur des
universités à l'université de la
nouvelle calédonie merci d'avoir apporté
votre éclairage dans cette émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]